hello everybody and welcome to episode
seven of buying and selling free to play
RuneScape I think this is going to be
our second to last episode CU we are at
about uh 3 mil plus uh 500k in items
which we'll sell off shortly here and
yeah so I think we can do it in two more
episodes and I'm kind of running out of
items to flip and free to play so there
wouldn't be too much Point going past
this um but yeah we'll jump right into
it here we'll get the mythal arrows sold
uh the margin did drop down so we'll be
selling them pretty much what we bought
them for so we'll just get our money
back for that but we did make money on
the um first half of the arrows we did
sell so that's still good yeah so we'll
sell those off and we'll find some more
items to
flip okay so for the second item here we
are going to be doing party hats I think
we just check the margin here we bought
them for about
57k and yeah so there's a 6K margin on
there so that's really good especially
since these uh sell pretty quickly uh so
we'll buy these for somewhere around
5100 uh
5170 and we'll buy a couple of these
let's see we'll do
50 yeah
50 and for the last item here we're
going to do the admin plate legs uh they
just consistently have a very big margin
on it like we yeah 15K margin on there
we bought them for 25 we sold them for
10 so yeah it's there's just no point
not doing this and they are mov decently
quickly so you can see the graph
here yeah see look it's way higher than
it normally is I'm not sure why it
fluctuates so so much but I'm not
complaining I probably made a mill off
this item alone almost uh so yeah we'll
try buying a couple of these for 10K is
and yeah we'll come back when some stuff
is
changed okay so we have fully sold all
of the mythal arrows so we got our money
back there and uh also we managed to buy
about 20 a piece of these items we were
buying so that's quite a bit um we
bought 21 of the plate legs I think 22
party hats um so yeah we should hope
hopefully be able to sell those for a
healthy profit hopefully the margin
hasn't changed too much um so what we're
going to do is just recheck it here then
uh put those up for
sale okay so the party hat set um we
just checked so see has a bit of a less
margin than we had before but we'll
still be making 3K a piece on those so
hopefully we could still get about 60k
from the party hats bit less but I'm not
surprised by how many I bought um so
yeah we'll plop those in there for
around
4500 and then we'll go check the uh
plate legs
and you can see there the pl legs still
have a really nice margin on them
they're still selling for 25k um so if I
do manage to sell these uh for 25k we
should make it over 200k from that
entire transaction which is awesome and
for the last item here I think we're
going to try the mithil kite Shield G I
had a bit a 4K margin on it but the
actual price has seemed very low so
we're going to buy 40 of these uh for
about 7K and we'll check back when they
bought okay so the uh party hat sets uh
we got about 3K per hat so we got about
60k since we got about 20 of those the
kite Shields we got three of uh making
about we bought them for all for 20K and
we sold them for 75k making about 50k on
the whole transaction and the plate legs
we sold 14 of them so far for about a
12K margin um so we got 168k from the pl
l so far plus we have uh I think six
more to sell um so that's going very
well and we're just going to continue on
I think what we're going to do is sell
some of the items we have in our
inventory we had some of these capes for
quite a while one of them was in my bank
um yeah so we'll get to doing
that okay so we're going to start off
just by selling the adamant PL legs here
we're just going to recheck the
margin um let's see so it's down 18K so
that's still okay we'll still be making
8K on each one which will finish off at
about 56 or 50k or something from the
rest of those we're just going to sell
off these team capes we've had for a
while we'll just put them in for 1 GP
and something kind of crazy here happen
so I'm I'm looking to sell it
200k I guess that's they sold for like
6K each which is hilarious I've had
these forever pretty sure I just got
them from the Wilderness but I that's
insane I don't know how I got so much
for these so I guess that was a pretty
Pro flip that was super
unintentional uh but yeah we'll take
that and we sell off the rest of the
capes I don't believe they go for nearly
as much but I mean those still pretty
good they still went for like 800 each I
don't even remember when I got those I
don't remember what I bought them for
how I even got them I think I got them a
long time ago when I was flipping the
team capes but uh I'm not complaining
too much those only went for 45 each
whatever okay so I think we're going to
do uh the adamant arrows cuz you can see
right here there's a 4gp margin on it
they move pretty quickly and uh it seems
relatively low compared to what it's
historical values are uh so we'll try
these uh at 73 GP each I think we're
going to do 20,000
um because why
not so I think for the last item here
we're going to do myth Ros as well uh
because they seem to work pretty well uh
one of the highest moving free topl
items and I think I just check it here
and it has a 2 GP margin on it which is
pretty good for the price um so we'll go
ahead and buy a couple of these and buy
a couple I mean 40K of course um so we
will check back when this is all
sold all all right so everything is sold
and I think we're just going to cut it
here and we'll have one more episode to
do um I almost have all the footage so
it wouldn't be too long until I release
it um but yeah so you can see here we've
sold everything like I was saying
earlier the admin PL legs we just made
about 50k on uh you can see right there
the uh admin arrows we made uh about 70k
on and the myth arrows about 60k um so
pretty good really quick so it really
didn't take very long so I liked it for
that but yeah so we'll call it here we
at about 4,200 we'll easily be a able to
get 5 mil in the next episode uh which I
should be able to release in about 2 or
3 days so I hope you guys enjoyed uh if
you want to see more content like this
just hit that subscribe button and uh if
you have any ideas for a series I could
do or any things you like to see just
leave a comment and yeah I'll see you
guys next time
[Music]